hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
in this video we're comparing apples
brand-new 2019 10.2 inch iPad right here
to Apple's iPad Mini 5 also a 2019 so
let's go ahead and get this plastic wrap
off of this thing alright let's take
this off and wow this is actually quite
a bit larger compared to the nine point
seven inch it seems like it's not a big
difference but it actually is it seems
pretty large holding them side-by-side
you guys can easily see a difference
this thing's so much bigger than the
iPad Mini five and before I start
comparing these two I want to point out
that we still get the same 12 watt power
adapter just like we used to get with
all the other iPads so right off the bat
I'm seeing a few differences first of
all it looks like the iPad Mini 5 has
thinner bezels on the sides right here
you can definitely say that you get
bigger bezels on the 10.2 inch iPad and
what's interesting is that this iPad
right here is the exact same size as the
iPad air for 2019 so it actually fits
the same smart keyboard as you guys can
see right here it's got the smart
connector just like the iPad air the
only downside is that the keyboard is
actually around 150 dollars so it's
definitely expensive to get on this
budget iPad so everything looks very
familiar on the front we've got the same
bezels all the way around
we got the touch ID right there let's
flip them over and on the back they
basically look the same as well one
thing I do want to point out before
setting it up is that the iPad Mini 5
actually has much better contrast as you
can see what the displays off it looks
really dark and black compared to the
iPad which looks a little bit grey and
it's also more reflective like you can
see the camera at the top alright so
let's get it set up now that we have
them set up let's start by comparing the
displays now with the new 10.2 inch iPad
it costs three hundred and twenty nine
dollars compared to 399 but on the iPad
Mini five you're actually getting a
limited display what that means is that
the display is actually glued to the
glass as one piece with the
anti-reflective 'ti coating compared to
the budget iPad that does not have a
limited display that means there's a gap
in between the display and the top glass
so check this out listen to this kind of
sounds hollow compared to this this is
very solid and you guys can see that gap
right here on the budget iPad it's
definitely noticeable and you're also
gonna notice this while using the Apple
pencil you actually see a gap between
the Apple pencil tip and where it's
showing up on the display now I don't
know if you guys can see this or not but
the iPad Mini 5 has p-3 wide color gamut
and the budget iPad does not so you
should be able to see an outline of an
image on the iPad Mini right here but
you can't see anything on the budget
iPad because it doesn't support those
colors and now let's test display
brightness as you guys can see right
here the iPad Mini 5 looks a little bit
brighter
the iPad Mini 5 has true tone as you
guys can see right there there's a
little true tone button and the budget
iPad does not have true tone so what
happens when you turn off true tone it
looks like the display actually gets
even brighter on the iPad Mini 5 so
you're gonna have a much better
experience on the iPad Mini 5 for the
display quality and now let's compare
the speakers with a song on YouTube
let's start with the budget iPad first
[Music]
[Applause]
now Before we jump into performance
which is the main difference between
these two iPads
let's first test out the cameras what's
interesting about the new budget iPad is
that it still has only a 1.2 megapixel
front-facing camera compared to I
believe it is 7 on the iPad Mini 5 and
you guys let me know down in the
comments below what differences you can
see between both of these selfies and
which one looks better and on the
backside we're actually getting
identical 8 megapixel cameras on both of
these and just for good measure let's
also test out the microphones on both of
these iPads this is a microphone quality
tests on the 2019 10.2 inch budget iPad
this is a microphone quality tests on
the 2019 iPad Mini 5 now before we get
into performance let's quickly mention
the battery life the iPad Mini 5 has
around a 19 watt hour battery compared
to around 32 on the budget iPad but
Apple still rates them for 10 hours of
use so we've got Geekbench for open
right here and as you guys can see we've
got the 8 12 Bionic right here and the
eight 10 fusion on the budget iPad and
interestingly they both have three
gigabytes of RAM let's go ahead and
start the CPU benchmark
now while this test is running I do want
to mention that the budget iPad has the
a-10 chip that has not changed since
last year it's the same exact chip and
it's actually the chip that came in the
iPhone 7 so it is pretty old compared to
the a12 bionic that actually has an
added knurl engine for augmented reality
and machine learning tasks so we got the
results back and as you guys can see the
iPad Mini 5 is getting over double the
multi-core score then the budget iPad so
you're definitely getting a lot of
performance with the mini and now let's
switch over and do the graphics test and
here are the results as you guys can see
we're actually getting 64 percent better
graphics performance on the iPad Mini 5
so if you're doing any kind of photo
editing video editing or even gaming
you're definitely gonna want to go with
the iPad Mini 5 or the iPad air that has
the same a 12 chip on that note let's do
some gaming and see what the differences
are for gaming performance now call of
duty mobile just came out
days ago and it's the perfect game to
test out for this comparison so we're
gonna start off with the iPad Mini 5
let's go ahead and go into the settings
and let's see what it's set to what look
right away we got very high graphics
quality and high frame rate let's go
ahead and switch to very high frame rate
as well all right so far it's feeling
pretty smooth yeah come on bro
oh we got me so far everything looks
perfectly smooth the frame rate is
really good I know you guys can't see
the frame rate because it's not in 60fps
but it's super smooth right now so
overall this is a really good package
because it feels really comfortable in
your hand it's nice and small and you
also get a ton of performance for gaming
call duty mobile plays perfectly on this
iPad now here we are on the 10.2 inch
iPad and as you guys can see this is
definitely much larger now here we can
see that we actually get the option for
very high and very high for both the
quality and the framerate which is
really really nice so I can already feel
that this is less comfortable because
these buttons right here I moved out I
might have to customize them but
definitely not as comfortable to hold in
the hand but one thing I'm noticing is
that you can easily see a lot more so if
you're looking for enemies further away
it's a lot easier to see there are a lot
of drop frames I don't know why it
defaulted to very high but it's
definitely not a smooth experience like
the iPad Mini 5 is definitely playable
but I don't think of these settings
definitely noticing some drop frames
so there you go as you guys just saw if
you definitely don't get the best
performance on the 10.2 inch iPad
because I did notice quite a few drop
frames or as I didn't notice anything
wrong on that iPad Mini 5 it was perfect
at the very high settings for both
quality and frame rates so if you're
gonna be doing gaming especially on Call
of Duty mobile you definitely want to
get the iPad Mini 5 instead of the 10.2
inch iPad and now let's answer the final
question which iPad is the best budget
tablet well to be honest the iPad Mini 5
definitely has the edge in the
performance but it does have a smaller
display you can actually upgrade to the
iPad air instead which is a little bit
more expensive I think it's $100 more
expensive for the air but for $329 this
is actually a really good package with
the 10.2 inch display it's actually
really nice and it does have the smart
connector so you can connect the smart
Keyboard and use it with that so that's
definitely a plus
and I think this budget iPad is gonna be
best for people who need a basic tablet
for things like YouTube surfing the web
and playing basic games and this one is
going to be better for people who want
to do some higher-end gameplay like Call
of Duty mobile fortnight and maybe some
photo or video editing or high
performance tasks like that so thanks
for watching guys if you didn't already
subscribed click that circle above and
make sure to check out some of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]